[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo je suis
ravi de vous accueillir ici au parlement
européen à bruxelles
c'est parti pour une demi heure
d'actualité européenne dans cette
édition nous partirons en roumanie
troisième pays dans le collimateur de
l'union européenne pour des réformes qui
menace l'indépendance de sa justice en
juillet dernier le gouvernement social
démocrate est même allé jusqu'à limogés
la procureur anticorruption une décision
qui a suscité une vaste opposition
populaire dans le pays
notre reporter est allé à la rencontre
de ces roumains révoltés par la
corruption dans leur pays
nous en débattrons ensuite avec nos
trois invités mais d'abord revenons sur
cet accord sur le breakbeat approuvé par
les 27 lors d'un sommet exceptionnel
après 17 mois d'intenses négociations
londres et bruxelles se sont finalement
mis d'accord sur les grandes lignes de
leur rupture
on écoute le négociateur en chef du
brésil pour l'union européenne
aujourd'hui nous sommes arrivés à un
accord juste et équilibrée avec le
royaume uni
c'est le meilleur accord possible étant
donné les circonstances a dream machine
à ratifier l'accord doit maintenant être
ratifié il est temps que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités l'accord
d'aujourd'hui aidera à créer une
confiance nécessaire pour négocier notre
future relation étroite qui sans
précédent fletcher en lait chaud chez et
pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau henrique
calvette chambon bonjour bonjour moi
vous êtes espagnol membre de l'alliance
des démocrates et libéraux pour l'europe
c'est ça oui alors dimanche à bruxelles
on sentait la satisfaction d'être arrivé
à un accord avec les 27 mai ils étaient
quand même difficile évidemment de se
réjouir du départ d'un état membre
oui oui bien sûr c'était tout le
processus était très traumatiques et et
les britanniques continueront à être
européen ils ne sont plus membres de
l'union européenne ça s'est très c'était
désagréable pour un projet pour un
projet aussi important à ce point
désagréable que nous espérons tous
qu'ils reviendront du clan viendront
dans les mêmes conditions mais au bout
d'un certain temps bien entendu bien sûr
techniquement parlant
le fait de pouvoir arriver à un accord
aussi difficile c'est toujours une bonne
nouvelle à court terme
et bien sûr le négociateur qui est
monsieur barnier est bien obligé de dire
que c'est le meilleur qu'il pouvait
atteindre est bon dans les faits le
parfait et en ennemi du bien il va
falloir il va falloir vivre avec
du côté du parlement on verra après du
côté des britanniques
exactement pas facile de se réjouir
totalement donc d'autant qu'on sait que
cet accord doit maintenant passer
l'épreuve des ratifications
parlementaires notamment la plus
redoutée celle de la chambre des
communes
au royaume uni on écoute la première
ministre britannique nous pouvons
soutenir cet accord nous conformer aux
résultats du référendum et avancer dans
la construction d'un avenir plus
prometteur et plus prospère pour tous ou
alors cette assemblée peut choisir de
rejeter cet accord est de retourner à la
case départ
personne ne sait ce qui se passerait si
cet accord n'était pas adopté cela
ouvrirait la porte à plus de divisions
et d'incertitudes avec tous les risques
que cela comporte
alors henrique calvette chambon que ce
pourrait-il se passer si la chambre des
communes rejette cet accord à mon avis
s'il le fait et non madame my sera
obligé de convoquer des élections ce que
je sois prêt c'est là dessus et dans ce
cas là je pense que ce qu'on va faire
c'est prévoir tout en prévoyant que le
29 les parlementaires d'ici par devrait
tous se coupent prévoir quand même une
certaine période de prolongation dans
les divisions dans le respect des lois
communautaires pour pour ne pas arriver
à traumatisme globale alors les
négociations pour arriver à cet accord
ont connu un rebondissement de dernière
minute qui ont même mis en danger la
tenue du sommet de dimanche dernier le
premier ministre espagnol menacé
d'opposer son veto à l'accord sur le
breakbeat s'il n'obtenait pas des
garanties sur gibraltar
cette petite enclave britannique de 7
kilomètres carrés située à l'extrême sud
de l'espagne
pedro sanchez voulait que soit entendue
dès maintenant que le sort de ce
territoire ferait l'objet de discussions
directes entre madrid et londres
il a obtenu gain de cause on écoute la
wii mais européens pour le prix mais la
veille pour la première fois depuis que
nous sommes en état membre l'union
européenne elle se positionne et
reconnaît la position politique du
gouvernement espagnol
la profession pour lui concernant le
différend avec gibraltar dans ses
relations avec le royaume latin entre la
fiom qu'on a vraiment mieux alors
gibraltar un fait l'objet dans l'accord
d'un protocole entier pourquoi ces
négociations de dernière minute de la
part de l'espagne il ya une spécificité
c'est que c est quand même la dernière
colonie qui reste en europe
aigle aux nues a dit qu'il faut des
colonisés il faut quand même prendre ça
je resserre est ce que c'est un moyen
aussi pour l'espagne un peu te prendre
sa revanche puisque quand elle avait
adhéré à la cee en ces temps où 86 ça
avait été conditionné oui le royaume uni
justement jusqu'à question de gibraltar
et d'hommes que le royaume uni soit plus
ou moins même avec les perdre les
périodes de prolongation il s'agit de
débats entre deux membres du club
européen n'est ce pas mais une fois
qu'ils sont dehors
il ya bien sûr une attitude tout à fait
différent où le reste des nations
européennes doivent protéger le leurs
membres leurs associés qui est l'espagne
et le reste bon bah c'est une discussion
avec quelqu'un du dehors
ce fils obtenu c'est le compromis que
dans l'avenir le conseil européen comme
tel et la commission tiendront compte
d'espagne quand il y aura gibraltar sur
la table
merci dans le plaisir notre invité
aujourd'hui cap à l'est désormais
direction la roumanie menacé de
sanctions par l'union européenne si elle
ne revient pas sur sa volonté de réviser
son système judiciaire au pouvoir depuis
2000 16 les sociaux-démocrates ont
entamé des réformes qui mettent en péril
l'indépendance de la justice et pourrait
permettre à des responsables politiques
d'échapper à certaines poursuite des
projets qui ont déclenché une vaste
opposition populaire dans le pays
notre reporter est allé à la rencontre
de ces roumains qui se bat contre la
corruption de la classe politique
un reportage signé flora sauvage
[Musique]
il y a trois ans jean a perdu son fils
alexandre ou dans l' incendie de
collective une boîte de nuit de bucarest
depuis il se bat pour faire la lumière
sur le drame qui a coûté la vie à 65
personnes comme en atteste cette photo
prise quelques heures avant le drame
c'est lui là dans le fond en train de
filmer son fils était venu voir ses amis
se produire sur scène dans le club on a
retrouvé 26 corps ils sont décédés à
cause de l'inhalation de substances
toxiques
les autres sont morts à cause de
l'incompétence des autorités
ce mot résume tout la colère de gens se
cristallise autour de la corruption qui
gangrène le pays
dans le cas de collective la salle de
spectacle ne correspondaient à aucune
norme de sécurité
les autorités sont suspectés d'avoir
fermé les yeux sur les conditions
d'accueil de cette salle qui ne
possédait pas d'issue de secours jean a
rendez vous au tribunal pour lever le
voile sur les circonstances de la
tragédie
et pour tenter de trouver les
responsabilités de chacun notre souhait
avec ce procès c'est de changer un
système corrompu presque malades
tout comme jean marianne à lui c'est à
nous a décidé de se battre pour faire
changer les pratiques pendant 24 ans
elle était infirmière dans le plus grand
hôpital de roumanie et face au manque de
moyens
elle a fait une grève de la faim sur le
matériel chirurgical il y a marqué ce
matériel à usage unique mais comme il
n'y a pas d'argent on nous demandait de
le stériliser et de le réutiliser
suspendu pour avoir révélé au grand jour
les dysfonctionnements mariana dénonce
aussi la pratique des pots de vin car
pour accéder à des soins de qualité il
faut payer à un moment donné j'ai dit
stop on ne peut plus avancer comme ça
le moment est venu de parler sur la
place publique pas seulement à
l'intérieur de l'institution presque
tous les jours les patients venaient à
la salle d'opération avec des enveloppes
remplies billets quand je découvrais ce
genre de choses je prenais l'enveloppent
de la poche du patient et je la mettais
à part dans une pochette plastique avec
le nom du patient et après l'opération
leur rendait cet argent en garde à toi
et surtout bats toi jusqu'au bout mais
oui bien sûr je vais continuer à me
battre
tu sais bien que je ne suis pas du genre
à lâcher ce soir mariana est invité à
participer à un débat organisé par une
association de défense des droits
humains en tant que lanceuse d'alert
elle est sollicitée pour parler aux
côtés d'un ancien ministre de la santé
celui ci est préoccupé par la dérive
autoritaire du gouvernement actuel qui
vise à faire taire toutes opinions
dissidentes vol dans l'état de droit
c'est quelque chose qui les enquiquiner
les recettes sont les mêmes partout
on l'a vu en hongrie on l'a vu en
pologne d'abord il s'attaque au système
judiciaire
ensuite il s'attaque aux médias et puis
à tous ceux qui pensent qu'ils disent
des choses qui vont contre le
gouvernement
[Musique]
bonsoir on ça va après avoir manifesté
contre la réforme de la justice destinée
à blanchir les politiques accusés de
corruption
la famille nicolas ou songent maintenant
à quitter la roumanie
on a tous hâte fort voici ce qu'ils ont
envie voici le mien
tous les jours ou presque de nouvelles
lois sont votées qui portent atteinte à
l'état de droit
ils les ont voté une par une et ce qu'on
croyait impensable début c'est devenu
notre réalité au quotidien c'est toute
notre famille est en roumanie
mes parents mes frères on travaille
beaucoup mais on a une vie décente et on
n'a jamais pensé à immigrer jusqu'à
maintenant
comme les nicolas ou de plus en plus de
roumains de la classe moyenne ne se
retrouvent plus dans un système gangréné
par la corruption
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir la
majorité social-démocrate a fait de la
réforme du code pénal sa priorité
une réforme qui pourrait bien faire
redescendre dans la rue des romains
[Musique]
et pour en discuter j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau renate weber
bonjour bonjour vous êtes roumaine
membres de l'alliance des démocrates et
des libéraux pour l'europe face à vous
aujourd'hui guillaume balas bonjour
bonjour vous êtes français membre des
socialistes et démocrates dans ce
parlement européen et pour compléter ce
plateau aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir gilles lebreton bonjour bonjour
vous êtes français membre du
rassemblement national anciennement
front national et vous appartenait au
groupe europe des nations et des
libertés alors première question pour
vous un renate weber aujourd'hui on a vu
dans ce reportage un sérum un révolté
par la situation dans leur pays
d'ailleurs à la fin de ce reportage on
voit même une famille qui songe à
quitter la roumanie
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup des romains qui ont
quitté le pays et les derniers années
vraiment beaucoup et nous regrettons
beaucoup parce que maintenant on manque
une force de travail en roumanie
révolté c'est une décision personnelle
de chacun beau et si c'était une famille
qui était révolté les autres peut-être
qu'ils ont essayé de trouver d'autres
moyens de vivre dans d'autres pays ce
que c'est la choix de chacun et moi je
la respecte clairement mais ce que je
veux vous dire c'est que vraiment je
regrette
et aussi je vois tous mes concitoyens
qu'après trois ans on n'a pas encore une
décision d'un tribunal sur ce qui s'est
passé dans ce vase de nuit dans cet
endroit où malheureusement à un incendie
horrible il selon vous qui est toujours
pas de réponse pas bon il y avait
plusieurs
motif à 10 ans il ya des expertises qui
sont contradictoires
puis un juge s'est retiré et on a dû
changer et commençait presque dès le
début alors bien sûr on trouve des
titrisations mais la vérité c'est que
c'est dommage qu'après trois ans on n'a
rien mais sur ce que signifie la
corruption je connais très bien la
perception qui existe dans l'union
européenne mais la vérité c'est que
d'accord avec des études qui ont été
faits récemment je veux dire le dernier
en sur des indicateurs qui sont objectif
la rue manistes c'est pas du tout le
pays le plus corrompu
c'est vrai en même temps qui a une
mouvement aussi dans les rues qui dit ça
tout le temps et surtout quand le
président d'un pays dit tout le temps
que son pays est un pays corrompu
alors bien sûr que la perception et de
cette manière
moi j'ose dire qui a en roumanie
beaucoup de choses qui se passent bien
beaucoup de gens qui sont des gens de
très bonne qualité et très honnête
y compris dans la politique mais en tout
cas la commission européenne a rendu
donc un rapport très sévère en sur
l'indépendance de la justice en roumanie
et sur la corruption est en baisse oui
je crois qu'en fait on est dans un
moment qui est très particulier c'est
que on voit bien que
naissent aujourd'hui dans plusieurs pays
l'idée que la les droits humains
élémentaires sont révisables finalement
que ça ne serait peut-être qu'une
culture occidentale et tout le problème
en fait il n'est que au sein de ces
mêmes pays il ya au contraire des
mouvements qui aspirent de plus en plus
et bien avoir ses droits humains
respecter c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
confrontations qui sont des
confrontations extrêmement forte
mais j'aimerais quand même dire une
chose parce que pour moi elle est
absolument fondamentale on ne peut pas
non plus ne pas parler de la corruption
si on ne parle pas globalement des
inégalités de richesse au sein de
l'union européenne parce que vous vous
apercevez quand même que les pays les
plus corrompus c'est quand même les pays
les plus pauvres commission moi j'y suis
tout à fait pour qu'il dénonce à la
corruption et j'appuierai toujours la
commission européenne quand elle le fait
j'aimerais aussi que l'union européenne
est une politique économique qui ne soit
pas une politique économique de la
concurrence de tous contre tous et qui
fait que les inégalités sont en train
d'exploser et donc de favoriser aussi
des comportements de corruption
il faut être logique j'allais dire et
tenir les deux bouts de la chaîne il ya
ce rapport de la commission open ya
également deux autres pays 1 la hongrie
et la pologne qui sont sous la procédure
de l'article de l'article 7
c'est une procédure qui peut mener
jusqu'à la privation du droit de vote au
conseil
est-ce que la roumanie pourrait être
finalement le troisième pays visés par
une telle procédure gilles lebreton
c'est tout à fait possible puisque on
reproche à ces trois pays la même chose
c'est une réforme judiciaire contesté et
donc dès lors que la pologne et à la
hongrie ont fait l'objet d'une dune à
déclenchement de l'article 7 on peut
effectivement s'attendre à ce que la
même chose arrive à la roumanie alors
moi évidemment je proteste contre cet
état de choses parce que je pense que
lorsqu'il y a des problèmes dans des
pays faut en discuter avec eux mais
sûrement pas leur donner des leçons et
encore moins allés les attaquer comme on
le fait moi j'aimerais quand même
rappeler que l'union européenne est très
très mal placée pour donner des leçons à
ces pays parce que ici aussi nous avons
des scandales qui sont considérables je
fais référence à la faire celle mayer
qui a été nommé en violation de toutes
les règles juridiques et tout le monde
est d'accord là dessus en violation de
toutes les règles juridiques secrétaire
général de la commission de bruxelles
qu'un mauvais exemple selon vous pour
les écrits bien voilà et à partir de là
l'union européenne est bien mal placé
pour donner des leçons
alors j'ajoute qu'en ce qui concerne le
cas particulier de la roumanie il faut
laisser sa chance à ce pays parce que si
on regarde sur le long terme
il s'est quand même beaucoup amélioré il
faut pas oublier que jusqu'en 1989 il
était en proie aux régimes communistes
terrible de sergé ce coup donc ça fait
moins de 30 ans donc même s'il y a
encore des problèmes de corruption ça a
été dit et c'est vrai eh bien il faut
quand même voir qu'il ya quand même une
amélioration de ce point de vue donc ne
pas l'accabler
si l'article secte sept étaient
déclenchées renate weber qu'est-ce que
quel serait votre sentiment
non ça n'arrivera pas et j'ai des
raisons très très fort pour dire ça
c'est parce que d'abord tous les lois de
la justice qu'on a changé on a fait ça
parce que vraiment on devait corriger
des habits qui se sont passées les
derniers années et je vous parlais ici
par exemple des protocoles secrets qui
ont été signés entre le service aux
mains de renseignement et le procureur
général et la vérité c'est que les
procureurs sont devenus des subalternes
des agents des services de renseignement
ça n'existe pas dans aucun pays de
l'europe et ça on devait vraiment le
corriger mais en même temps il ya une
collaboration très étroite avec la
commission de venise même l'airé
partialement jusqu'à présent des
recommandations de la commission de
venise la commission des listes qui est
un organe consultatif mais rendez-vous
dans les réformes constitutionnelles
mais ça on a été déjà transposé dans la
législation interne
en plus nous avons une cour
constitutionnelle qui travaille très
très bien dont les décisions sont
toujours obligatoire et ils ont été
toujours respecté alors nous avons des
mécanismes vraiment pour corriger ce
qu'on doit corriger dans un pays alors
justement j'aimerais qu'on écoute la
première ministre roumaine ancien
eurodéputé en d'ailleurs qui est venu
défendre ses réformes début octobre
devant le parlement européen
non les led jallet josty thiellay la
nouvelle loi sur la justice rend son
indépendance à la justice
il n'y aura pas de décision politique
pour les nominations et les renvois des
juges independenza est totale
l'indépendance est totale ce n'est pas
du tout restreint si et je vous assure
que nous sommes de bonne foi et que nous
allons tenir compte des recommandations
de la commission de venise donc renate
weber selon la première ministre pas de
mise en danger de l'indépendance de la
justice c'est ce qu'elle a défendu
devant le mail la dépendance de la
justice a été affecté par le service
romain de renseignements par les
politiciens etc ça ce que vraiment on
doit cesser maintenant sur le rapport
mcv no2 de la commission européenne il y
à une déclaration officielle du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature qui se
déclarent étonné de ce qui a dans ce
dans ce rapport parce qu'on leur donne
des ordres à kinomé équipe ne pas nommer
et ça c'est incroyable 1 écoutez la
commission à ses responsabilités et
c'était un mécanisme de coopération
je ne vois plus la coopération du tout
alors guillaume balas le groupe des
socialistes européens comptent douze
élus roumain quelle est votre position
sur ce qui se passe en roumanie et le
chef du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates a indiqué qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'expulsion
oui alors il l'indiquait notamment parce
que je fais partie de mouvements de
benoît hamon en france génération et
qu'avec mes collègues dans le groupe f
samedi
nous on a réclamé le départ justement de
ces de ce parti socialiste romain pas
simplement pour les questions de la
corruption mais c'est aussi des
questions de position sur la société en
général et notamment ce qui avait été
fait avec la promotion d'un référendum
pour en fait interdire le mariage
homosexuel
entre les personnes homosexuelles de m
de même sexe et là il ya une
contradiction si vous voulez flagrante
entre une les positions qui sont les
positions de la gauche en général et les
positions qui sont celles de ce soir il
exclut oui c'était un moment faut
clarifier
moi je ne porte pas de comment dire
d'oukases et de jugement mais simplement
j'aime bien quand on dit que je
travaille politiquement avec des gens
parce que je suis dans le même camp être
sûr qu'on soit dans le même camp et là
pour le coup on voit bien qu'il ya des
contradictions qui sont des
contradictions des contradictions
manifestes
alors maintenant moi je pense qu'il ya
un équilibre à tenir je suis toujours
très attentif sur le fait qu'il n'y a
pas une certaine forme de racisme
occidental par rapport aux pays de l'est
moi je m'occupe de questions sociales
avec madame hébert d'ailleurs
très attention à ça c'est à dire ne pas
avoir ce discours toujours qui est très
méprisant en vérité et en même temps
faut pas faire de relativisme cédait
faut pas dire on accepte pour les autres
ce que nous ne voudrions pas accepter
pour nous mêmes donc à partir de là il
faut quand même qu'il y ait des règles
communes j'avais dire qu'il soit admise
qui soit respecté par tous et en effet
en premier lieu par les autorités
européennes
ça serait quand même le minimum pour
qu'ensuite on puisse dire à chacun qu'il
faut rejoindre ces règles parce que s'il
n'y a pas de règles communes il n'y a
pas de destin commun voilà c'est les
deux bouts de la chaîne à mon avis qu'il
faut savoir tenir dans le premier
ministre hongrois viktor orban il fait
toujours partie du parti populaire
européen et lui oui en effet et sociaux
démocrates qui sont au pouvoir en
roumanie font partie du groupe
socialiste moi ça ne me dérange pas si
vous voulez ça au contraire accrédite la
l'exactitude de notre analyse selon
laquelle maintenant la grande
distinction politique qui prévaut en
tout cas en europe et je pense
ailleurs aussi ça n'est plus la
distinction entre gauche et droite qui
est historiquement dépasser c'est la
distinction entre nationaux et
mondialiste et en l'occurrence les
sociaux démocrates ont une sensibilité
nationale ils défendent leur nation et
moi je suis de ce camp là aussi c'est à
dire que je pense que chaque état doit
avoir sa souveraineté et chaque état
doit être libre de prendre ses décisions
en matière sociétale
le référendum sur le mariage homosexuel
si c'est une décision du peuple roumain
il faut s'incliner
ça n'est pas à moi français de leur
dicter ce que je pense sur la question
chaque peuple doit pouvoir trancher donc
c'est notre position et par conséquent
moi je pense qu'il ne faut pas donner de
lui son chien des mines a été rejetée un
bien sûr il ya eu que 20 % de
participation c'est la raison pour la
nuit même pas valide parce que la
participation est seulement y avait pas
assez de participation mais le seul fait
de l'avoir tenté si vous voulez moi je
reconnais la légitimité au pouvoir de
tenter ça après c'est le peuple roumain
qui décident ce qu'ils veulent a
manifestement il n'était pas d'accord
avec cette mesure il a racheté très bien
mais là on a là on a une différence qui
est une différence en effet très
importante c'est que moi je crois
aujourd'hui que il ya des tas de gens
roumanie avec qui je n'ai pas de
différence est qu'en fait le vrai
clivage il n'est pas entre roumains et
français entre polonais et allemands le
vrai clivage il est au sein des sociétés
entre ceux qui veulent les
évitez l'égalité sociale l'égalité des
droits dans tous les domaines et ceux
qui pensent aujourd'hui que non il n'y a
pas d'égalité qu'à une hiérarchie de
l'ordre des inégalités et il faut les
accepter et donc moi je refuse assez de
ce discours
moi je connais des gens en pologne qui
se battent pour les valeurs qui sont
exactement les mêmes que les miennes
alors en tout cas je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur un événement en particulier
un qui a déclenché la colère des
roumains c'est le limogeage en juillet
dernier de la procureur anticorruption
une femme de 45 ans devenu le symbole de
cette lutte contre la corruption en
roumanie
rien qu'en 2017 un millier de personnes
ont été renvoyées devant les tribunaux
dont trois ministres cinq députés et un
sénateur
on écoute l'ancien chef du parquet anti
corruption il est de bon sens de
constater que l'orientation politique
actuelle ne conduit pas un système de
justice efficace mais vise plutôt à le
bloquer bloquer le système judiciaire
excusez moi mais ici il s'agit vraiment
de beaucoup de détails que vous
probablement ne connaissez pas quand
elle a été révoqué c'était surtout parce
que hélas il n'a pas respecté trois
décisions de la cour constitutionnelle
qui lui interdisait clairement de
investiguer les moyens d'opportunités
sur une législation qui venait du
gouvernement ça c'est quelque chose
d'important en plus excusez moi mais
malheureusement elle a fait des bonnes
choses mais en même temps que c'est elle
qui a signé ce protocole secret dont les
procureurs devenait les subalternes des
services de renseignement il avait
l'obligation de rapporter au moins
soixante dix 70 dont 60 jours ce qu'ils
ont fait dans leurs investigations
ça c'est pas vraiment un comportement
qu'on peut accepter pour un chef
en plus vous ne parlez pas des centaines
des cas où les ceux qui ont été rendus à
la justice ont été acquittés et ce je
parle de ça vous ne parlez pas des
autres procureurs de ce département anti
corruption ses subalternes qui
maintenant ont été jetés à la porte et
sont dans des investigations criminelles
alors excusez moi c'est bien plus
compliqué que ça je sais que vous l'avez
transformé dans une sorte de jeanne
d'arc
mais elle est loin de ça alors
j'aimerais qu'on vienne au niveau
européen parce qu'un élément important à
souligner c'est que la roumanie va
prendre la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne à partir de janvier
et il s'éteint semestre très important
puisqu'il va les voir le breakbeat et
les élections européennes et ce qu'elle
en est capable
cette roumanie de prendre la présidence
bien sûr moi je n'ai aucun doute
là-dessus la roumanie est aussi capable
qu'un autre pays de présider l'union
chez aucun doute absolument lorsque je
dois dire d'ailleurs un premier ministre
depuis 2007 on l'a déjà connu dans
d'autres pays mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est justement le doute
qu'on est en train d'instiller sur cette
capacité de la roumanie
moi je crois que l'union européenne
reprochait à la roumanie d'essayer de
lui résister dans un certain nombre de
domaines et donc on essaye d'en tirer la
conclusion que du coup elle ne serait
pas capable de briser l'union moi je
crois que ce n'est pas du tout vrai est
ce que vient de dire madame est très
important sur cet exemple monté en
épingle du limogeage de la procureure en
réalité il semble bien qu'elle ait
commis des fautes professionnelles
donc au lieu d'en faire une jeanne d'arc
effectivement il faudrait voir la
réalité en face c'est que là
probablement la roumanie a bien agi en
limogeant sept procureurs et rien que
cela ce courage politique qui consiste à
limogés en pro coeur lorsque c'est
nécessaire
moi je trouve que c'est plutôt bon signe
je pense que la roumanie saura prendre
ses responsabilités à la tête de l'union
alors quand même trois premiers
ministres depuis 2016 et la démission du
ministre des affaires européennes juste
deux mois avant de prendre cette
présidence tournante
guillaume balas je veux dire quand même
une chose c'est que en effet attention à
ce qu'on dit quand on dit d'un pays
membre de l'union européenne est-il
capable de prendre la présidence de
l'union européenne je crois qu'il faut
voir comment ça pourrait être ressenti
par ces pays aujourd'hui et vous savez
ça accentue beaucoup après les fracture
est ouest et ça complique beaucoup de
notre travail en tant que député
européen pour trouver des solutions
communes sur des sujets très importants
je pense au dumping social par exemple
parce que voilà dans les pays de l'est
c'est aussi une forme de ras-le-bol de
toujours penser qu'ils seraient les
responsables aujourd'hui de tous nos
maux qui serait corrompu
etc etc donc je pense qu'il faut faire
vraiment attention aux formules bien sûr
que la roumanie est capable
politique aujourd'hui que ville l'europe
est une crise que vivent tous les pays
européens
donc la question aujourd'hui qu'il faut
se poser c'est comment on y répond il ya
ceux qui vont répondre comme monsieur et
bien c'est la voix nationale
d'accord chaque pays est différent et
finalement il a une identité
particulière à chaque à chaque pays il
ya ceux qui comme moi qui pense qu'au
sein de tous les pays européens
aujourd'hui il ya des clivages qui sont
les mêmes entre ceux qui sont pour
l'égalité et ceux qui sont pour
l'inégalité que c'est ça
fondamentalement le clivage qu'il faut
installer pour avoir une vraie
confrontation politique en europe
moi je veux dire que pour se préparer
pour le lab la présidence c'est pas des
choses les derniers deux mois c'est
vraiment un processus qui a commencé il
ya plusieurs mois et s'est très bien
passé jusqu'à maintenant je ne me
souviens pas par exemple du questions
similaires quand la belgique a eu la
présidence du conseil parce que la
belgique n'avait pas le gouvernement
plus de un an et demi je ne me souviens
pas ni en tchèque république tchèque où
la situation était presque similaire
alors je vois ici des problèmes pas
vraiment dans mon pays la roumanie à la
tête de l'union européenne on en
reparlera évidemment dans nos prochaines
émissions c'est en tout cas ainsi que se
termine notre débat aujourd'hui merci à
tous les trois d'y avoir participé
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis et
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur nos différents sites lcpan
public sénat et rtbf.be très belle
semaine à tous et à très bientôt
[Musique]
m